Parfois, je téléphone à Timothy au milieu
de la nuit et je laisse des messages qui ne sont
que la chanson, n'est-ce pas, je chante juste
le O mais les mots sont des cris brouillés
dans le
fond [Musique] [Musique] Je voulais le détester, je ne le fais pas.  Je
n'aime pas les gens plus jeunes et
talentueux, c'est enragé, mais
ensuite je suis allé sur le plateau et en fait, je l'ai
aimé. Je lui ai posé quelques questions de test
comme celles que je lui ai demandées pour me donner des
informations sur quelques grandes stars avec lesquelles il avait travaillé
et  J'ai de la bonne saleté alors as-tu gardé cette
saleté tu pourras l'utiliser un jour peut-être que c'est
mon
système donc c'est comme ça que tu continues à
rouler ouais noir
[Musique]
mec je pense que Love Actually est le meilleur
film de Noël de tous les temps J'adore ce
film et  nous verrons comment les gens
réagissent mais Love Actually est parfait et
Hugh danse et Love Actually est
[Musique]
euh
ouais, est-ce qu'on est juste derrière
toi oh
je ne pense pas qu'ils soient réels oh ils sont
faux comme
[Musique  ]
nous, je dirais qu'environ 70% était du vrai
chocolat, la chocolaterie était euh, la
moitié des choses dans lesquelles vous mettiez les pieds
étaient comestibles et mais si vous faisiez une
erreur, ce n'était pas agréable pour vos
dents si vous faisiez une erreur
ouais  non, je pensais que ce serait du plastique
parce que je n'avais jamais fait de film à gros budget
avant le premier jour où j'ai rencontré un
chocolatier et j'étais comme un quoi
et cette femme extraordinairement douée,
Gabriella coo, qui était véritablement l'une des
plus grandes patias du monde et  les
chocolatiers ont passé six mois avec nous à fabriquer
ces chocolats exquis, c'est une
artiste, ils ont aussi bon goût qu'ils en ont l'air, ils
n'ont pas besoin d'avoir bon goût
parce que les acteurs sont des menteurs et ils peuvent
prétendre que n'importe quel vieux déchet a un
goût de euh
fuagra
dès le début  Je ne me souviens plus de quelle séquence il
s'agissait, je pense que c'était quelque chose qui
nécessitait d'être léger sur les pieds et euh
et absolument joyeux et j'ai l'impression que c'était
la première fois que j'ai vraiment cliqué
pendant le tournage où je me sentais bien,
c'est une marque.  nouveau sentiment pour moi, tu
sais, travailler sur un film pour être aussi léger
sur mes pieds a dû me libérer et
j'étais un peu blessé parce que euh Paul King
m'a téléphoné et m'a dit euh tu sais que je fais
ça Willy Wonka nous sommes seulement  ayant un
OA lper, je pense qu'il devrait être sarcastique
et grincheux désagréable et je pense que tu es
la personne idéale pour jouer le rôle mais
c'est ce qu'il fait avec moi, il repère mes
défauts et ensuite en fait des personnages,
il a fait la même chose sur  Paddington aussi,
il ne semble pas être ton ami, il
regarde plus le côté frak show de ta
gr oui le côté freak show pauvre
[Musique]
moi c'est une période très différente de sa
vie donc ouais absolument c'est un peu l'
autre bout du monde  L'autre fin de la
vie du personnage dans la version de Tim Burton
ressemble presque à une histoire de Rédemption, n'est-
ce pas ? Je pense que notre histoire parle beaucoup plus
d'un innocent qui reçoit les premières
frondes et flèches d'Outrageous
Fortune, c'est très ennuyeux
[Musique]
insupportable.  Parfois, j'appelle Timothy
au milieu de la nuit et je lui laisse
des messages qui ne sont qu'une chanson, n'est-ce pas, je
chante juste le O mais les mots
sont flous et il dit toutes sortes de
choses qui ne sont pas appropriées, il y a des
cris en
arrière-plan que nous avons  300 suites toutes
impeccablement planifiées, donc nous en
ferons beaucoup, bonne chance pour cela,
nous ferons passer Marvel pour des amateurs,
ça va être
incroyable, je pense que la mort instantanée, j'ai
toujours voulu empoisonner quelqu'un, je suis
très intéressé.  dans Poison mhmm toi je
dirais euh tu sais quoi ouais
je ne connais pas un chocolat qui transforme
ton nez en oreille ouais c'est bon tu
vois tu es parti Sur Real après environ une
heure d'interviews il y va il se transforme en
Salvador
[  Musique]
d'
accord